a buddy of mine sold his company for a
couple billion and he's been in a little
bit of like a rut since then yeah kind
of interesting after people self a lot
of money why do you feel like they go
into a depression or a funk after they
sell a billion dollar company they lose
the vision I think the vision is another
word for hope so hope for a better
future and you basically give that away
to someone and then the Hope ended up
yielding you more than the money ever
does but he said this one thing to me
I'm just looking for my next big bone to
non and that visual for whatever reason
like stuck to me and so I'm like I've
seen a big bone To None knowing that
I'll never chew through the entire bone
but being pumped every day to just get a
little bit further